this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
Terry wanted me to do a a talk similar
to one I gave it back I a while back so
if you were at that talk you can leave
now and pretend that you heard me give
it again um I'm just going to tell you
some stories guys that's it the point
here really is just a show to share with
you how the humanities and technology
have always been interwoven and in the
in the things that I've been involved
with personally that I feel are
important in some way I don't i could
easily talk about other people's work
but at this point in my life I'm going
to talk about mine because I sort of
can't remember other people's work as
well so here are some stories about
crossing boundaries and here are the
destinations we're going to look at
quickly I'm have a little intermezzo
about design education that I won't take
too much time on this is really a
history of ledges and the first big
voyage that I took was this book
computers as theater this is a picture
of the tatt or elliptical many of you
may be familiar with it and in this
image for me everything is represented
that's important about my observations
about the relationship between computers
and and technology or technology and
theater the first perspective I find
especially interesting so if you have
type one of these alleys on this stage
you would turn into a giant because
there's the buildings in the scenery
gets tinier sort of The Hobbit trick so
there's a there's a kind of forcing of
that single client perspective that is
something that really interests me and
has changed a lot in my career the
notion of the representation of a place
and that actors are representing
characters is important hey this is not
the Teatro Olimpico this is the Ohio
State Theatre where I worked this is one
of those wonderful posed pictures that
you hate from jakes
plays but working as both an actor and a
director in the theater gave me some
unique and varied perspectives on why
theatre is a good metaphor a useful work
of old metaphor for what it is that we
do when we're designing interaction as
an actor certainly you've got several
people that you're interacting with a
simultaneously right the other players
and the audience and whoever that is and
you can feel the audience and there is a
difference as you all know between live
theater and television or film as a
director to me this is a role of design
a good metaphor for a designer because
as a designer you need to create a
vision of what the thing is going to
look like and be like an act like and
then get people who have all different
kinds of skill sets to see that same
picture and go down that same road so
that's another similarity I think
between the art of theater and and what
we have to do as designers of
interactive media things started
changing for me in the late 70s
everybody who lived through late
seventies could say that this was an era
of improvisational theater and audience
involvement on the stage became a big
deal on Broadway like Dionysus in 69
living theatre other institutions
started to do improvisational work with
audiences and the boundary between the
audience and the actor began to morph a
little bit and that's actually
reminiscent of some of the things that
happened in the medieval theatre but
let's not go there at that point in time
I was directing an interactive this is a
picture from an interactive version of a
play about Robin Hood that i co-wrote
based on the 11th century materials
although he did slip maid marian in
there and you can see that here how the
actors are respecting my leadership just
by looking at their faces not
so in in this version of robin hood a
menstrual goods the children who come to
the building we did this on the ohio
state oval begin singing us on and it
asks the children to follow him her and
I was standing around in costume and I
have this memory of a little kid asking
me what what kind of tree is that what's
this tree and I said well this is an oak
tree in Sherwood Forest and he was like
I hope tree in Sherwood Forest it
totally changed him I mean now he's
going to look at oak leaves differently
you know something magic happened there
that was important plays into the story
so the audience would shout directions
and suggestions to the actors as the
hell is going on so there was a kind of
participatory authorship you might say
of what was happening we had a wonderful
instance where we had an audience of
blind children who who could hear things
going on in the broad sword battles and
we're giving really interesting tips
like he's moving around behind you he's
using his left hand you know stuff that
was not the sort of thing we were
hearing from side of the audiences
anyway you can see that I'm moving from
a career in Shakespeare and Gilbert and
Sullivan into a more improvisational
space and that is exactly the time when
I met a guy named Joe Miller was working
up with the Battelle Memorial Institute
in a Columbus Ohio and he was running
one of the earliest computer graphics
labs around one night under the
influence of his personality and other
seventies things he took me to see his
lab and when I saw there were images
coming in from the Viking mission
painting themselves very slowly on the
screen and I thought oh my god whatever
this is I want a piece of it you know I
want to be involved with this this this
is speaking to me
and to a deep part of me as strongly as
the theater speaks to me well about a
year later this guy quit battelle and
formed a company called cyber vision
this was in 1976 cyber vision was a
little box that hooked into your TV and
it it read code at 200 bought from off
of an audio tape and we had 2k of usable
grams and we were using alpha numeric
keypads to navigate and he asked me I
was working on my PhD in theatre well
would you at that time I was doing some
really boring stuff about Bernard Shaw
he said would you like to come and work
here and we want to do some animated
fairy tales so I got very excited and I
immediately came to work there and I'd
sort of reinvented cel animation because
I was too dumb to like figure it out I
did things like lip-sync snakes and
designed interactive versions of things
like I'm trying to think the princess
and the pea the problem was that when
you were loading only in 22 k and you
were running off of audio tape you had
to do converging nodes and every load so
that the player couldn't make a real
difference in the action because you
couldn't branch very far you had to
always come back to the same point for
the next data load the cool thing about
using audio tape though was that you can
use live human voices and cue them to
movements on the screen so there were
interesting trade-offs what I learned
from that experience more than anything
was that the genuine meaningful action
is essential to a sense of engagement
and presence really that you have to be
able to make decisions that make a
difference even if it involves an
elaborate branching structure but people
don't really go for converging nodes you
know it gets really boring and we were
seeing some of this nearly video game
industry so here's here's kind of a map
of that
me and I'm using maps because my like
maps so you can see the humanities
territories above the technology
technology territories below and and I
was really exploring this chance
intersection emotionally and
structurally for me between theatre
enactment representation and the
technology that I had just been exposed
to socially some points on that map
obviously acting an improv came first in
the world of humanities for me um I had
the experience of seeing a production of
lantern imagica in Prague in the late
70s this was a multimedia company that
did amazing things with projection
they're still around does anybody know
these guys were there so for example
they had a dancer with a with a round
screen that he was holding in his hand
he was moving around the stage and they
were projecting a woman on to that
screen with perfect accuracy and later
on I kind of used that technique in a
production of Alice in Wonderland where
we had people walking in and out of
video through slits and a scram Lantern
imagica gave me this notion of the sort
of permeability of of the proscenium the
permeability of acting and technology
combined and then it could be done and
it could be done well I mentioned
participatory theatre living theatre
Dionysus in 69 one of the things that
really took my breath away about
medieval and late early Renaissance late
medieval theatre was the commedia
dell'arte and what was going on there
was that a troop would these guys were
actors whose tradition had survived
Hadrian's condemnation of the theater
and and they were wandering around even
before the coup em kore-eda stroke came
brought the theater back through the
church they used the stock characters
from the roman theater pretty much they
had memory
bits of business you know the donkey
enema joke or the braggadocio soldier
with the maid joke or whatever and they
had stock characters but what they would
do is when they came into a town as a
traveling show they would find out what
was going on in the town you know what
what you know I this is her some sex
scandal is-is the government corrupt did
somebody just get murdered and they
would improvise their work so that they
shaped those issues into the play and
then plop down these bits of business
called lot see our little pieces of
script in between so this is an early
example of how you could combine a sort
of sense of personal relevance with
things that were already fixed and said
and it gave me another view of how
interactivity might be able to work I
won't go too far with that I fell in
love with Aristotle's Poetics and that's
kind of where I started my journey
although I could have easily have
written computers estate or using a
Brechtian model and I kind of wish I had
so look for it in a rewrite which is
coming out next year now we look at the
technology side of that i told you about
cyber vision the company with the
interactive fairy tales and the notion
of interactive stories at when cyber
vision folder we all went out to work
for this upstart company called atari
came in 1979 I was the first woman and a
home computer division I can remember I
had a phone and a cubicle no desk no
tear so I was sitting there on the floor
further when in the ladies room there
were all these guys in there smoking
dope and I said dudes you know what I
work you're now I'm going to need to use
this actually as a restroom so I kicked
them out and eventually I ended up in
the atari research lab because I got up
to here with the game side of the
business not the game mechanics but the
way the company was running it they were
really these guys from Warner believe
that if they had a hot license like
Superman that that would magically make
a great game and they were giving people
not enough time and too much money in
there were a lot of drugs and cleaning
anyway L&K got hired from Xerox PARC to
run the entire systems research lab
when it looked like I was about done
with the software side I ran across the
street and I said to Alan you gotta give
me a job please you know I know what
you're up to I know your work please so
I turned out to be one of the very few
people in that lab who wasn't straight
out of the architecture machine group
which later became the media lab and L
was terrific what one of the things that
happened though was that he wasn't there
very often he was always gone so a bunch
of us got together we decided we would
invent his replacement dr. Arthur
official who had a history of working
with the British Postal Service and it
also developed squid jerky and other
interesting products and Arthur official
came to be the head of the lab we got
him an employee number i impersonated
his voice well using a an even tied
harmonizer so I answered the phone for
him he was British and this culminated
and 12 of us authored email from him and
it culminated in a live teleconference
between Arthur and the rest of the lab
so we're back in a conference room
somewhere I'll wire it up and I'm a drag
with a beard I'm wearing Michel ney
marks jacket and every time the scene
cut to us live there would be a
different travel poster in the
background so I looked like he was
levitating few people notice this there
was an assassination attempt in the
teleconference of it it was nutty
afterwards we did live Q&A and people
kept trying to break me they keep trying
they kept trying to prove that I was on
tape that this could that be live you
know so when we finally got the the
ideas through the people that it was
live we all SAT there we ended the
teleconference we said well we just
invented a person and we did it as a
collective and this person's behavior
was emergent from all of us watching
each other improvise him that that stays
with me as the kind of thing that now we
maybe take for granted but then it was
pretty impressive I remember Douglas
Adams was in the audience that day was
visiting a lab and went to dinner with
him and he looked over and there was
still
a little bit of crepe hair of my tea he
said that was you he was the only person
who recognized me which is great anyway
edit our labs I got I got introduced to
concepts of artificial intelligence
unfortunately I went down the road of
expert systems which turned out not to
be the best choice but at least got my
feet wet the guys from the Media Lab
brought in a bunch of information and
ideas about the notion of presence and I
should have been co-present with other
people or being present in a place where
you're not I'm thinking how Michael
named Arkin scott fisher for example
bringing those ideas into the lab that
was also the moment at which i met Don
Norman who has been consistently mentor
even though he is a crab cake he's one
of the smartest people I know and and he
gave me an opportunity to pursue some of
the ideas that were starting to coalesce
in my brain so I have to thank him he's
a little town on my map another
milestone for me was producing little
computer people at Activision rich gold
program it was anybody know it yeah
you're not that old but you studied it
right you had it okay so yeah dude
looking on your screen right and he's
got you kids it's like a plan view like
I Love Lucy and you can see him go up
the stairs and you could see is bad in
his kitchen is its refrigerator and the
piano in his living room and you have to
start to take care of him you talked two
of you you remind him to go to the
grocery store you make sure you know
he's got enough to eat and if he's
really happy he'll play you something on
a piano so it was like a goldfish bowl
sort of thing and a kind of interaction
that felt entirely different you know
from playing games the cota there is
that when the sales guys would take this
product to trade shows they would forget
to take care of him and he died so when
they went to demo and maybe all green
and in bed right dad so we had to make a
version of it where he didn't die so the
sales guys could show it
anyway that that the way that felt that
interaction felt was just like reaching
through a portal and directly engaging
with the character so that's another
step on that journey and Apple I worked
at the human interface group and worked
on the guides project which was an
exploration of using storytelling agents
as guides through the Encyclopedia
Britannica westward movement chapter and
so we created personas with very
different points of view pioneer woman
you know bear skinner native american
etc and we shot video of stories that
would show up depending on what the
person seemed to be searching for and
often would challenge the point of view
that they appeared to have as they were
navigating the material so that was that
was about the time that they did the
apple commercial what was that called
that agent knowledge navigator that
thing was happening and then of course
Microsoft brought us the paperclip and
Bob and all that stuff anyway in guys we
really did try to use storytelling and
narrative as a way to help people
navigate information so there's another
vector that came in for me and all that
stuff sort of collided into this book
computers this theatre which is changing
you know and I guess that the big
learning for me out of this is a seeing
through structure I am an unrepentant
structuralist I have difficulty reading
French post-modernism although the board
is an exception but i feel that
structural models are incredibly
important and when i chose to use in
this book was Aristotle's Poetics but
there are others that are just as
effective and some that we might even
think of ourselves so that was a big
ah-ha for me and then learning through
the experience of all these nuances of
how I'm feeling about interacting
primarily with agents or personas and
games on the screen and trying to try to
wrap my head around
so when it's working and you feel like
you're right in there with that little
guy how does that happen you know how
does that happen and and the way it
happens is that the cognitive distance
is reduced I don't use these terms in
the book i'm going to next time in other
words you're no longer thinking of
operating the computer in order to talk
to the little man you're just talking to
the little man and this notion of the
barrier or the proscenium that was the
desktop in that day goes away and that's
sort of the the big ah-ha for me in it
it guided my work for a long time
afterwards it came out in paperback with
the most horrifying cover I've ever seen
but I did get to duel ranting about
virtual reality in the next version i'm
going to be talking a lot about
emergence you can tell by the way i talk
about the book now that that has a lot
to do with some what I think I
discovered and I'm also using much more
biology as structure than than just
literature literary theory okay here's
second map second map takes us into the
wonderful world of virtual reality do
you guys remember virtual reality so hey
remember that there were like actual
rock stars and virtual reality like
Jaron Lanier with his dreadlocks and
Scott Fischer so it was it was a long
time but this sort of impulse to get
into it I think comes from being an
actor you know put your head in it be
there with your body in some other space
with other characters it's such a
pleasurable thing when you're an actor
to do that so the fantasy was to be able
to dive into a dream physically as well
as emotionally without you know I mean
this is one step beyond getting rid of
the interface as a cognitive thing it
actually gets rid of any kind of two
dimensional barrier that we might think
we have so that's the context
I thought a lot about authorship in the
beginning of that explanation
exploration and the sense that when you
have when a computer game is working
well and many different outcomes can't
occur at many different stages to the
extent that that's true the player
becomes a co-author and the control of
the maker or the designer is reduced to
a certain extent in other words you
can't have absolute control of what kind
of experience somebody's going to have
saying worlds of Warcraft or second life
or you know going back space invaders
you even then you don't have a complete
control like the author of a play or a
director would so as we look at it when
you're faced with a situation where
players and participants begin to
co-author the quote plot of what's
unfolding in real time the author loses
formal control and has to rely on
material control to predispose people to
make dramatically interesting choices
yes is your sense I'm curious why you
think that immersive virtual reality
isn't nearly as pervasive today as the
enthusiasts thought 25 years ago and I'm
wondering whether it is it because
diving into the dream is really
important and in fact we can do it with
a book we don't need you all exactly or
or is it book hut or or you know we
don't care about that any of the dream
or dining the dream this doesn't work
even in VR or what's yours because it's
kind of surprising in some sense yeah my
sense of it was that that two things
happened one is that nobody could make a
workable business model for full of VR
like if you put it in a or any kind of
public installation you've gotta you
gotta have at least five minutes of
dwell time for it to work at all right
so the throughput goes way down and it
doesn't work for the economics of like
an arcade or an amusement park given the
cost of the equipment
also in some cultures specifically in
Japan people had real difficulty around
the hygena wearing a head-mounted
display they just didn't like the way it
felt and then we got nailed by this
whole BS about desktop VR where
assertions were made that you could
simulate virtual reality on a flat
screen and to the extent that the word
got watered down and sort of turned into
a turbo kind of you know how turbo just
got looted or design thinking desktop VR
it's like everything's ER did it in so
it kind of melted nobody kept working on
that problem I think it's back to a
certain extent people discovered the
power of audio and constructing
environments that aren't as expensive
but are just as immersive for example
but at the time it was that nobody could
come up with a business model that
worked even as SDI whose business model
was primarily based on training you know
train people drive caterpillars and
stuff went out of business so that's
what I think happened but it's still
worth talking about if you don't mind
which that we should just ripped through
this partner well yeah it was so there
are several little things going on here
and I don't dwell on too many of them
but when Rachel Strickland and I thought
I conceived of the project that we ended
up doing at Banff it was really about
the relationship between landscape and
narrative and we were trying to create
an interactive environment where people
were encouraged to create narratives and
leave them for others to listen to to
share narratives and and engage in
narrative play within a space that
emulated the natural environment where
we were doing the installation so we use
different means of capturing that
natural environment and had a lot of
magical affordances and in the in the
environment we got questions a lot about
well why are you doing this why are you
capturing the environment that we're
standing in you know and making this
interactive thing and the answer is this
is indexical
to the environment we are pointing at
the environment we're loading it up with
with meaning and affordances for play as
you get out there and stare at rocks and
see faces it's the same reason people
make photographs or paintings they're
indexical there there's a spiritual
element involved even I think anyway
took a lot of heat for that tough Barry
Lopez was my hero in those days still is
my favorite writer and my most important
literary influence so very was there
with me all the time I'm not going to
talk about space we an interesting thing
happened as we worked on this particular
project by the way I'd done vr before
with telepresence research and all that
jazz but that's so nasty we don't want
to go there the the collaboration
element between the technologists and
the artists in this project was really
hard it was harder than anything I'd
ever done before because their gifts and
views were so disparate and there ended
up having to be sort of a palace coup to
get things straightened out so I kind of
discovered that they were bound there
are some limits you can reach in terms
of how diverse people are unless you
have agreement on a grand strategic goal
and the way we got through that Knothole
was to agree on a grand strategic goal
which wasn't in fact to produce this
massively cool virtual reality
experience in three months at the banff
centre with you know the first silicon
graphics reality engine off the assembly
line it was to make a design statement
it was to say that this glorious medium
which is currently being used to train
people who drive caterpillars or
astronauts could it could be equally
useful in helping us live out if it's a
a futurist hypothesis where we want to
find out what happens when certain
affordances are in the world right that
there are many other uses for the medium
then were being exploited at the time so
it was a design a grand strategic goal
is a design statement and then the
takeaways we could make from having
hissing and seeing people use it that
was a new thing for me and I thought it
was cool that we came together around
that understanding of it that does that
make sense I learned a lot about this
the senses I guess that's more like
science really but proprioception was
incredibly important so for example I
love this story and in the day of early
virtual reality people wore a helmet
with a head-mounted display on it these
wide-angle video screens stereo optic
and then they had a glove usually which
they pointed they could they could get
pulldown menus with the glove I always
thought that is the stupidest thing I
ever heard why do you go to the trouble
of emulating a three-dimensional space
and then put a pulldown menu in it are
you nuts anyway so so the attendant
direction of movement was that was the
point and there were gestures that you
could use to to make certain things
happen so you did not moving like this
right so what we did was placeholder was
to make two little grip ease that were
just cheap little plastic guys that
looked at reeces looked at how hard they
were being squeezed we put a sensor on
the belt and a sensor on the helmet so
we took direction of movement from the
pelvis and direction of gays from the
head and we gave people two hands so it
went from here to here right it was it
was all present we don't put up all
these other vectors of movement and it
allowed people to do very different
things so that was important and as you
know now we were just hiking at lunch
about connecting Lee and some of the
other great stuff that's come along that
takes advantage of that diamond
technology land i must confess i was
under the influence of dr. Leary to the
extent that I was his producer in the
video game business and so I got to see
this sort of sex appeal part of your and
the early jenna monic stuff and you know
the whole Gibson crowd knowledge as but
Timothy was so hopeful about what PR
could do for society I sort of fell
under his spell
I was irritated to death by polygons at
that point because they looked awful it
just look like all the same it had no
texture yeah I texture mapping it didn't
do it for me so that's why we we fooled
around with different ways of capturing
and representing national environments
that didn't involve polygons so one case
we used really an auditory map with a
three-dimensional sound and one of the
venues we did a tiled video map of
another and we did a virtual relief
projection and another video on a
virtual relief shaped screen just
because I hated polygons I learned a lot
about direct manipulation that it wasn't
just drag and drop stuff that if you
could actually get hold of something and
move it even though we weren't
simulating gravity their direct
manipulation took on a much deeper
meaning when you can actually pick
something up and move it so we have
these things called voice holders there
were rocks floating around with closed
closed eyes and closed mouths and if you
grabbed one it would open its lies and I
would say I'm listening and you can tell
it a story and when you were done it
would close the size and open smell you
can put it here and then somebody who
came and tempted could hear the story
that you'd put in it and what ended up
happening was as people came through the
environment they started building these
lattices and walls of stories that they
connected to each other then at night I
would go in like the janitor and take
out all the dumb ones that said you know
Suzy loves Frank and clean up the mess
anyway that the the grain strategic goal
the purpose of the system was the main
point I've said that before so we ended
up with the placeholder virtual
environment and I believe it's a direct
ancestor of char Davies incredible work
with immerse called Osmos if you don't
know about this or haven't seen it it's
really worth looking at it's an
incredible exploration of the
capabilities of VR so diving into the
dream really turned into a lesson for me
and telling a news story about what a
technology was for how
worked and communicating discoveries by
making things if that makes any sense it
was a great trip it was a wonderful time
we had 13 computers and duct tape you
know here are some pictures you can see
the relief projection on the top of the
waterfall so we had video running on
that grid which simulated the shape of
the waterfall in the middle years you're
seeing some of the graphics for the
characters that inhabited this space it
was a two-person interactive environment
which I believe it was the first of and
if you are um there was a big argument
raging at the time about what how people
felt about their bodies and virtual
reality and I was noticing some gender
differences I was hearing men say in
general I can see from any perspective I
can I can I can be anywhere here and
they would describe it to me more or
less in plan view and women were more
likely to say I'm taking my body into
this environment and they would describe
it to me in elevation so that was
something that led me to do gender
studies later the other thing is that
when you first came into the world there
were petroglyphs of animals and they
were telling little stories about
themselves and if you got close enough
to one i tole you in come closer come
closer if you stuck your head in it it
became your body so for example you were
embodied as crow if you walked to crow
and one of the design problems we had
was how does crow fly I went around
asking people how do you fly in your
dreams you know my design research and
they're saying I'll go like this or and
we're doing hydrofoil things like this
and I was just stymied and then I
realized this always means flying so we
had to then figure out how to measure
what a flap was and tune flat bangin and
I was the flap estándar got these great
muscles right in here you know so the
first time it's like three big flops and
your three inches off the ground and the
next time it's out of the simulation and
you're looking down and it like down
there so I had to do a lot of flying and
it was really fun
so I'll go on to purple moon it's
another journey with some different
things on the map but it didn't rutland
has nothing to do with purple man except
we were kind of in a rut with computer
games at the time there had been no
games specifically designed for girls
interest except one Barbie game that
came out i think in 1987 and the
designer sat at a conference that they
were throwing marshmallows as the
gameplay because girls weren't very good
with projectiles i wanted to throw
something at him so after after you know
17 years of producing and designing
basically material that was geared at a
male audience we everybody just said
yeah of course this is this is boy stuff
into a certain extent it still is I got
kind of sick of it I got kind of sick of
the rules of gameplay that I had to live
by in that world and I get sick of going
into my kids 6th grade class and saying
all the girls sitting in the back and
all the boys using the computers because
those guys by playing video games had
learned that if you bang on return 27
times something's going to happen where
the girls are thinking I'll break it you
know there was a huge divide and and so
we had really two goals in mind but I'm
getting ahead of myself I started with
gender studies talked to a lot of
different people read a lot of stuff
looks at play theory brain-based gender
differences utterly taboo to talk about
in the 80s you could not talk about that
it was like off-limits but there are
actually some pretty significant brain
based sex differences and they're
overlapping Gaussian distributions you
know it's not like everybody's one way
and everybody's the other but it is the
case that females tend to be body
centric navigators which is why we turn
wraps upside down and males tend to be
able to dead reckoning and work better
with plan view representations and there
are all kinds of exceptions and nuances
there but that is a fairly large
difference the other difference is that
females tend to perform less well on
mental rotation exercises with an under
time pressure so for you know you've
seen those tests where you say okay
which of these is the picture of this
pipe from the left or something and you
have to you have to imagine it in a
different orientation so if you've got a
clock running as in a computer game a
female is going to take more time to
solve that problem why because their
body centric navigators they literally
imagine themselves moving out of the
other side well man can just flip it
typically speaking now if you take away
the time pressure performance equalizes
but think about side-scrolling computer
games okay you've got you've got to do a
rotation to do the side-scrolling if
you're a body centric navigator and you
also have to do a translation from the
plane of the screen to the keyboard to
the plane of the screen so no wonder
right that we had girls not very happy
never mind the content with with the
form of computer games in the day so we
used we interviewed about a thousand
kids all over the country girls boys
parents on another 500 experts of
various types to get our data so it was
a really well funded by Paul Allen
research project I have this great
memory of taking the prototype even
showing it to Paul and he said um can
you do this for boys and it's like
really really are you you didn't pay any
attention guys but I'm glad you gave me
four million dollars um there that there
was an ethical goal involved for us both
in terms of the making of games that
spoke to females and and the the making
of games that enabled women to get and
girls more comfortable with using
computer technology yeah he is my bad so
it seems like science fiction is also
very tailored towards male audiences or
at least it has been historically and
that has it seems it has less to do with
metaphors and body interactions than
computer games so do you see I mean body
is the keys to well who's writing the
books who's writing the books you know
that's one question you have a pretty
solid meal authorship and science
fiction although I you know I have a
total science fiction nut so I'm
probably not the right person to talk to
about this I think a hard science
fiction is harder for girls in lemon
because generally speaking they're not
taking those classes in high school
their interest in that in those things
is not inflamed or engaged in any way so
it's harder to read the hard science
fiction will go over and read Arthur
Clarke or you know vernor vinge II or
William Gibson because that's much more
narrative and less hard science and I
think that's just an artifact of the
choices that girls and women have made
as a result of gender labeling not a
gender difference but labeling in this
culture I can remember when I was in a
physics class in high school I was the
only girl there and my choice was okay
and I got to stay here and never have a
date and I dropped the class you know
that was how it was and 16 and it
continues to kind of be that way but I
think science fiction is becoming more
broadly it you know disseminated
especially because it shows up in film a
lot I'll try to get through this quickly
I want to say that I learned a lot about
strategy and tactics in this enterprise
and Rob calls at the Laurel maneuver Rob
my husband what I learned and what I am
able to pass along mounted designers is
that one strategy cancer two different
grand strategic goals we usually look at
it the other way got a grand strategy
and strategies in support of it but you
can have a strategy that serves two
different goals so one goal is get girls
hands on the computer and another was
through the content to give girls
emotional rehearsal space for their
adolescent challenges and I won't go
into the content but if you're
interested in it look at utopian
entrepreneur and that sort of saves us
when we're faced with working in
commercial environments that we might
not particularly agree with but
if the work we're doing serves a grand
strategic goal that we have as human
beings that maybe has cultural
significance you can make a case that
it's worth doing anyway anyway that's
another conversation have I covered all
of this oh one thing to say is that we
used a we invented an interface that we
called emotional navigation so that you
could mouse over the main character at
various points and hear her the choices
she was considering and how she felt so
I I don't know I feel like I just want
to be mean right now and sometimes
whining worked in that game there was no
way to win it what happened was that
plot was just all over the place and and
lots of little Easter eggs and stuff but
the idea was that girls that age have
had tween girls tend to have a sense of
inevitability about their a social
situation and about who they can be in
the world and that step getting from
there to a notion of personal agency is
probably the major stepping stone into
becoming a teenager for all of us I'm as
opposed to a tween and then you kind of
have to step through it again and I
different form as an adult so we were
trying to get to build something healthy
for girls that were kind of paralyzed in
that space so we had to grant strategic
goals we use one strategy does that make
sense this was a big deal to me at least
to discover that I learned a lot about
distribution retail environments it
turned out to sell computer games for
girls you had to you had to go into the
dealer to serve your dealer retailer and
provide them with the whole aisle you
know the end caps the setup arrangement
we had a player park right next to
barbie fashion designer even though I
could strangle Mattel but we had to give
retailers a huge amount of support to
even get it in the door with this kind
of game we also by the way gave the game
major cooties if a boy a boy wouldn't go
near it just even the packaging you know
because what we wanted not to have
happen was for boys to play and say well
this is lame and their sister say oh
okay
we'll play it you know we wanted it to
just like suck from the get-go have
repellent powers and that was great so
the New York Times guy gave me Pandit
and and the separatists community Pandit
but we were in the top 100 games for two
years running with with those games and
with I found out I discovered some
things about the power of transmedia
this is another kind of way of thinking
about osmosis through the membranes of
technology and fiction that if you can
extrude an object that's real it also
shows up in this game or a little
character that's real or physical that
shows up in this game the world starts
to take on a different kind of
dimensionality and we also did this in a
virtual wave by allowing by soliciting
girls to write for the school newspaper
of the characters and we would post that
stuff on our website so there was a real
sort of social network built in to the
way this thing rolled out in fact after
our board shut us down because they were
more interested in putting their money
in Internet companies that had no no no
real product to warehouse and no
business plan looked like easy money at
the times they just basically pull up
stakes and tried to get us to go into
chapter 7 which is bankruptcy from what
you do not emerge we ended up selling to
Mattel but they mattel at that time
bought up every girl game company
literally in the space and killed all
but one of them so that whole movement
just died because Patel was defending
his Barbie franchise at this point I
wouldn't do again because I don't need
to now there's enough going on on the
web and even in massively multiplayer
games that the the problems we were
trying to solve aren't present so this
is an artifact of cultural history but
it brought me a lot of insights and I
wanted to share it and it's just totally
central to this whole exercise was human
centered design research yes so I want
to push back on
actually it feels like in terms of
getting girls hands on a finger and
certainly there's been tons of progress
and see if women are actually more
activist media apps phones all these
things that really liked a lot of that
but in terms of perhaps some of the
goals of giving rehearsal space in these
kinds of things I'm less convinced that
we've made progress wondering how do I
tell every kind of a about it yeah
I mean that's not there that to a large
extent and I think in the same way the
kinds of things we're doing with
augmented reality or really trivialized
and paying very much less attention than
they should to the natural world so
there are a lot of holes in what we're
doing now I agree there's I wish
somebody would do it all right so
quickly here we are at our first III
that's my daughter who just had a baby
just gave me a grandson playing around
with a giant luck or at e3 e3 was great
I had my daughter's be the booth babes
so it would come up to the sales like
come in and say mister you gotta come
see that you know you can't turn that
one down so we had huge amounts of
traffic at the booth deserve some of the
products we made you can see the secret
stones and stuff anyway you know long
story short nobody got rich the thing
got sold to motel and killed but during
the time that it lived it had a great
audience I think it made a cultural
difference in the world and I'm still
proud of it and I learned a lot so there
you go I wrote this book the first book
I would have written would have been
really bitter and I had to get over i
get uh sir Mahmut that stuff out after
you after you get clobbered like this so
i got was able to then go back and look
at why I done it in what I learned from
it and there's a lot about business in
this book as well as uh as well as the
history of that endeavor so now I get
about twice a week I'll get email from
somebody who says I just wanted to thank
you I played those games and I was
thinking about some today and I send
them a copy of this that says here's how
the sausage was made you know and it's
fun because often they'll get back to me
and say you haven't do something soon
dude you know I know what you're talking
about so it's fun this I'm going to skip
over because I don't think we need to
talk about
and I've talked to a lot go next please
so this is kind of where I am now I do
recognize this map do you know where
this is this is Mendocino Cape Mendocino
and the map is from Gulliver's Travels
so it's a little distorted but you can
kind of make out the landscape new
Albion here this is the part north of
Mendocino I guess and it had sort of
mystical significance in the day so this
is kind of where I am now I guess
sailing with my little boat and here be
monsters but we're starting at the
technology side now I've really become
tremendously interested in distributed
sensing primarily by having exposure to
the work of shaun white at Columbia who
is now at nokia labs which is quickly
circling the drain so i don't know where
he'll be next but he's amazing and he's
in a long of your program so now we can
have like large pictures of large
expanses of the natural world with
heterogeneous sensing to model a place
in a much more accurate dynamic way that
that so we're still about plays here but
to me that's just incredibly important
now distributed computing as as a model
I bring it up because I think there's
some failure modes involved with it you
know about distributed computing like
you sign up your CPU hours while you're
asleep to go work on Ceti or that that
somebody uses your CPU to work on
protein folding or some large problem
that even supercomputers can't solve the
difficulty with it is have you tried to
do this the UI's sucks beyond belief and
you get you never get a representation
of what's being discovered you know the
larger view everybody is participating
but you don't see any results you're
just sort of lending your CPU so that's
not very satisfying I guess so when you
put those two observations together
with the ubiquity of mobile devices and
um participatory sensing becomes a much
more interesting way to think about
looking at the world in a dynamic way
that involves all of us sort of
crowdsourcing a picture of our world
this is a little side effect talk about
augmented reality for a minute this is
another technology that I think has
enormous promise and yet what do people
use it for you know you see these great
apps where you aim this thing down the
street and it tells you where there's a
good restaurant or where's the nearest
mcdonalds and then you've got a very few
things like star walk and leaf snap
they're they're helping you look at the
world around you and see it in a
different way to me that's a really
important necessary thing that I myself
and I think most of us as designers
ought to be doing is to pierce the
spectacle to a certain extent and get
around back on the scenery and have a
look at this down here and look at it in
ways that make us fall in love with it
again because of my hypothesis is that
the light is stronger than fear as a
motivation for changing your perspective
on things that's a side channel so I am
very interested in participatory sensing
in ways of seeing a ways of seeing earth
where's the scene Gaia as a system and
all of its little component parts if I
had an appt an AR absol at me looked at
rhizomes I'd be completely thrilled just
thrilled beyond belief if I were able to
participate in a project that that
helped us look at climate you know a
temperature change species movement from
local places and join together to build
a larger picture of that you know
somebody's doing stuff there are people
doing stuff in that vein I think a
larger project is called for so I'm a
subscriber to the Gaia hypothesis
interesting that about eighty percent of
the scientific with biological sciences
community does subscribe to this notion
it's not it's still many of us feel like
it's
edgy like it's woo woo the Gaia
hypothesis to work of Lovelock it's not
considered woo woo by the science
community what this says is that that
the earth and its atmosphere and its
biosphere could be looked at as an
organism with constituent parts
including the minerals and stuff and
that this thing works as a system in a
certain way to keep us within a range of
homeostasis in climate and it depends on
a lot of stuff like biodiversity global
warming the warmth of the atmosphere etc
you tipped that thing too far you lose
the homeostatic shield that we have and
things just go haywire that's I'm
oversimplifying but it's really worth
reading love like has a last book called
a the the changing face of Gaia I guess
there it's really thinking about the
larger system of earth as being the
thing that's affected by climate change
so reading margolis and love lock has
changed my life this notion of nature
both nature and Technology okay I'm
winding down here this this is my wisdom
than I can offer today we have a problem
in the technology community and in
culture in general of thinking of
technology as the other as this thing I
use as this thing I make as this thing
I'm sometimes afraid of that's not true
technology is an extrusion of the human
spirit and it's just as much a part of
us as anything else we've ever made and
use everyday like clothing to other it
you know is to invite a way of thinking
about our relationship with technology
that doesn't lead us in a positive
direction as far as I'm concerned
likewise we other nature we talk about
the natural world as if it was over
there the natural world is in this room
it's in your body it's in your closest
in the sky it's coming through the air
vents you know we're worse we're soaking
in it
we're constantly immersed in the natural
world no matter what structures or
architectures we find ourselves in two
other it to talk about it as if it were
something other than us leads us in the
wrong direction in terms of what we do
with the capabilities that we have
that's a preachment and and that's where
I'm trying to put myself at this point
in my life is to think about what is the
good to take the things I've learned
like the Loreal maneuver you know
somebody's gotta grants teach goal to
make my key and I also you know hook
something on it that gets us started
looking and falling in love with world
that we could take better care of so I'm
down with that I've learned recently
that you kind of need the spectacle but
that's another talk one of the biggest
conundrums of this notion of
participatory computing or even
distributed computing is okay what does
it look like if I want to make a display
of what people all over say Canada are
sensing what does that look like Barry
Lopez once said to me that when a
painting doesn't have vanishing point
perspective we call it primitive art and
he said we ought to call it community
art and it gave me a clue that there's a
real challenge in terms of information
representation to look for alternatives
to the the perspective POV that were
used to when we're looking at
information this crowd sourced and I
would just love to work on that problem
too so see me after class and rob's term
for all of this Alicia nanigans this guy
in gardening which I sort of like it's
it's a kind of mindfulness that I think
we lack sometimes and that new
affordances that we have right now can
really turn that around and I'm really
excited about it so there's where i'm
sailing on the sea and thank you for
listening to me tell my stories
questions
oh those are there's another little
pieces of final Kota here this is lb on
California I know if you can hear it I'm
not hearing the audio and we're kayaking
through CP we haven't
free Mitchell like
there's Albion
right ah just had to have that little
norcal whoo-whoo moment for you ok any
questions coming sis for our top tower
design for the world is probably not
going to work and now I hear the last
slightly talked about buying gardening
this seems like a very very top-down
approach to the X Inglewood oh nice did
you see yeah I can see how you would
read that but when you I guess I'm so
there's this business in in the Bible
about domination right that man is here
to dominate the plants and the animals
and you know run the show that's top
down right gardening is something that a
lot of people do in a lot of different
places and sometimes they have farmers
markets and you know so as a metaphor
thinking about gardening as being
mindful and cultivating things that grow
in the earth that we need that's why I'm
using the amount of four I don't mean
lets you know quickly put fertilizer on
everything and right okay although we
could other questions comments yo the
other way I feel like our response to it
the many years is actually think just
confuse technology out into the natural
world we need to place computer vision
yeah infrastructure right are you
advocating something that doesn't
require that something that perhaps more
attractive ship and technology yes it's
a perspective shift and I would put it
alongside your infrastructure model the
difference is that infrastructure well
it's not different infrastructure often
just grows so you could put it the same
way the difference is that when you
think about the infrastructure of this
building you really can't say that this
is all everything about the building is
infrastructure but when you think about
when you think about not uttering the
infrastructure and think of it more like
the circulatory system and start looking
at things with the with that perspective
in mind you get to a more
generic not generic all encompassing
metaphor I guess and I and I sort of
prefer the notion of not uttering in the
contexts that I'm using it I think that
two metaphors can easily live side by
side I get upset when people say well
well let me give you an example from
drawn from reality from Shaun White's
work they were they had a distributed
sensing environment in a hectare of land
and different kinds of sensors did
giving different kinds of information
saboten and they invited some botanists
in and some of the botanist got hardened
tablets and some of them got augmented
reality see-through displays and when he
asked the guys with the tablets what was
going on they said the sensor is getting
information it's transmitting it to my
computer my computer is constructing a
display for me and when they ask the
guys with a head-mounted displays what
was going on they said the plan is
sending the information so the cognitive
distance got collapsed now that's
dangerous if what you're doing is the
McDonald's thing you know I mean that's
a two-edged sword but but that's kind of
what i mean about like breaking it down
and seeing it as not this other thing
over here sending stuff to hear i'm one
of the same granted i always have been
right but to see the world differently
guilt um so I was sort of really
exciting when you're talking about some
of the storytelling behind the AR stuff
and how you might use that to introduce
something new into the environment and
see how people behave with that new
thing when you're constructing those
stories though and you said that one
important piece was this audio and that
the visuals maybe not as important
depending on the context what what is it
that you look for in that creating a
story is it more about the story or is
it more about the environment what
you're talking about VR not a are right
I think it's both
I think one thing is the story that a
person can construct by interacting with
the environment so therefore that has to
do with the designed affordances of the
environment and the way they predispose
people to have dramatically interesting
experiences so that's the story from the
inside out the story from the outside is
that we've pigeon-holed this medium into
a certain set of purposes that it
doesn't have to that doesn't have to be
exclusively what we use it for we can
blow it out and you can say the same
thing about augmented reality early AR
applications on our cell phones that it
really tend to be commercial social
superficial things and we can do much
more with them and there are examples of
that and i'd like to see where that
happened to help ok yes you talk about i
love it so you'd be talking about that
story that people didn't you know a lot
is that was created ascension and then I
think of the sort of emergent behavior I
keep wondering how you would predict
that why would you think that people
would do that I didn't okay it totally
surprised me it was emergent behavior I
thought people would leave little
stories in those rocks because that
affordances for well we we brief to
people before they came in so they knew
that there were voice holders but they
also were pretty obvious what they did
the fact that people work together and
arrange lattices was an emergent
phenomena do you think that would be a
vita verde that's all people would do
that yeah i mean if i have a real system
today and I want to you know see what in
life and behavior might happen is there
is that a systematic way I could go
about it what is it still dr. Drake well
so just if it's a hard question i think
a fundamental principle of emergent
behavior is that there's a relatively
small and of rules and it's in a group
emergent behavior situation like saying
ant hill or be
I there's a small end of rules if you
change one of those rules a little bit
completely different things can happen
to the group behavior so as long as you
have the small animal rules to play
around with you can tweak them in
simulation and you may discover using
easing ideas drawn from swarm
intelligence and stuff like that you may
discover the likelihood of certain
things to happen but I don't think it's
ever going to be like utterly
predictable if it were I'd die of
boredom all right I mean this is how we
learn stuff when people make things we
didn't expect right the telephone was
invented to transmit symphony concerts
from one city to another
hi yes some of the most visualization a
lot i was particularly intrigued by
brief comments about information
representation and so I was hoping you
might elaborate at a sense you were
pushing back against some forms of
representation or ways of looking at
this collected data it's important you
you're more about I'm just wondering you
know it's not a problem i can
immediately get a grip on and i can't
i'm working on it but you know reading
and looking at stuff but why do you gets
like it's like a pulldown menu in VR why
go to the trouble to involve people
widely distributed over space to create
a database of you know sensor data or
whatever that contributes to a larger
model and then reduce that again to a
single point perspective it doesn't make
sense I am I making any sense at all
you've example the single point
perspective you have involved so let's
say I'm getting sensor data about a
little like Joey toast thing about
radiation after Fukushima and we can see
hot spots on a map and stuff now the way
you're going to look at that is like I'm
looking at it from here but what if I'm
looking at it from here even though I'm
there you know I mean you want to be
able to not just move your POV around
but get it's a mapping problem and maybe
it's not possible but what I would like
is for people to be able to get you know
sort of an equivalence of value looking
at the distribution of data without
having to go back into my little head in
my little eyes do you know how do we
give people the sense that they're
looking at something that each part of
which is alive it comes from something
alive did you see Lauren carpenters red
green thing at siggraph you saw that
that that's the kind of thing I mean you
know he gave everybody in the audience
is a stick like a paint stirring stick
and once there was a tab on it and one
side was bright red shiny and the other
was bright green shiny
and he had arranged he'd built a
computer program that could look at the
colors and and do things what happened
was you can see a representation on the
screen of the whole audience and you
couldn't tell where you were because it
was so you know 5,000 people in a hall
you really couldn't see where you were
and the first thing he said I think was
to just like okay everybody on the left
go green you know so people are doing it
and then we got around to okay let's see
if we can spell where it was a short
word or something like that you know it
was astonishing how quickly people were
able to create imagery not knowing where
they were by looking at that view and at
the end of the thing they had us flying
a microsoft flight simulator with these
sticks we crashed it didn't we yeah but
it was up for a while you know it's like
you straordinario I guess that's that
eerie sort of distributed feeling that I
would love to see in an information
representation of a crowdsourced or
participatory thing I don't know how to
do that but I'm like obsessed with it
what helped okay well thank you i think
we've overstayed our welcome here so
good thanks very much
you